hi there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch this video
from top screen who does these awesome
tribute videos for many comic book
fandom and characters it is called Logan
suffering we're gonna be in a good mood
after this I can feel it this is one of
our top rewards your requests coming
from Lance door Canadian man firefighter
you've heard of shot him out before you
might even hear his name shout on
Collider videos from time and time again
and the movie trivia Schmo down he just
wants to hear his name shattered out
because what he really wants his fame
and fortune but he's not getting that
being a firefighter he's being disgraced
his girl and his kid constantly spitting
on him at home saying why are you
pursuing your life Realtree
internet-famous
loser yeah but here we are today doing
your request let's watch it you know I
love you Lance like a father is forced
to love his out-of-wedlock son
[Music]
cage fight let me tip you gave you I
[Music]
never asked for this right Charles never
asked for this
Taliban never asked for this and there's
six feet under the ground it happens to
people I care
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is one part of a person's life
death
see you on your back that's what
everybody holding your own heart in your
hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Dark Phoenix is next that's right yeah
get it I'm so excited for that pump
definitely got me a pump to not see
Wolverine in the upcoming x-men and
highly talked about yeah it was
heartbreaking I know it really reminds
you of yeah all the suffering and all
the struggle that Wolverine is a bit
over time and all the low points and his
troubled existence sometimes you see
these videos that they make that will
amplify a certain quality that I didn't
quite pick on prior and then you know
the way you edit it you go oh yeah
that's drew that level of pain and
sacrifice was made constantly that's
just never been the vibe or tone that's
really struck within the context within
these movies but Wolverine he primarily
suffers that's his job Josep onset yeah
it's like alright another performance
where I'm having a miserable time in my
life like there's something about having
a strong regenerative ability that makes
you just prone to yeah living a very
suffering existence because it makes you
witness to all the pain and life Jon and
makes me witness to all the hardships
that come along your way I mean
especially when he has to outlive
everyone that he ever it connects with
her it gets close to that the level of
weight that's imbued in his performance
I've heard that said about in the
Wolverine when she tells him that he's
dying with his laying on his back
holding his heart in his hand that that
was meant as a foreshadowing for that
moment where he's holding x-23 his hand
it was that a coincidence or there was
that something that was confirmed by
James bangle than Hugh Jackman I never
bothered to look that up I've always
thought that might have just been some
cool tie-in that fans made themselves
yeah I mean given the difference in tone
and everything from the Wolverine to
Logan I don't know I honestly I wouldn't
put it past them if that's really like
maybe that's what James mangle
really wanted to do and maybe he had it
in mind but at the same time I guess
yeah my instinct would say happy
accident yeah but I still really like
the connection here I thought overall
just the way that they source clips and
stuff like that it was really focused
even borrowing from the older movies
it's like as infamous as x-men is for
not having a great time line continuity
I thought all the footage they chose
really complemented the theme and really
felt like a complete through line of
this guy's life because it's interesting
too - yeah like Hugh Jackman obviously
doesn't suffer as much as Wolverine but
he does you know have to do some
difficult stuff on set and to watch him
go from young Logan in the first movie
to old man Logan in a video like this is
kind of interesting - oh very
interesting it struck me as odd whenever
I see that famous moment from Logan now
when he's running he's slashing people
through the woods I think it's the ADR
moment that went online I know I see him
doing the ADR for it in the room and now
I could never see that scene as the same
thing now I'm always imagining you jack
when doing the ADR that's you've never
seen that oh yeah that's why I'm not I'm
not as big on behind the scenes as most
people only because it pulls me out of
watching something because I'm so aware
how they made it and maybe oh yeah I
remember when he was in the booth yeah
but you know Hugh Jackman he does seem
like someone who's gonna be insanely
hard to not only you can't top the guy
but at least match the guy in this level
of commitment embodiment I even
rewatched x-men Days of Future past
recently gearing out for Dark Phoenix
and I don't really I love that movie
when I first saw i for some reason i
rewatch i was like
Cornie yeah but he's still amazing like
Hugh Jackman's still great and that's
the one consistent he gets about all
these x-men movies no matter how
terrible an x-men movie can sometimes be
if it's a great one he usually steals
the show and if it's a bad one he's
usually I'm so happy for him that he got
it truly had this you know like him in
Robert Downey jr. just yeah it was to
see if I were never gonna see them
collide on screen together but at the
same time it's really cool they gotta
have this long lasting legacy like they
gotta put a stamp yeah a finite stamp on
it it wasn't just like they left the
franchise one day you know now if
anybody else picks up the character is
gonna be like James Bond
they're the Sean Connery's of these
carrots that's what it really is at this
point and also the the the song this guy
chose for it and it's really cool ever
since Red Dead Redemption 2 came out
I've been hearing a lot more of these
kind of songs maybe because of the kind
of soundtrack that Red Dead 2 has and
also with having kind of an apocalyptic
Western vibe with Logan if it's very
well for this sort of somber tone that's
going for here and nylon-string yeah
yeah yeah yeah you feel like the desert
landscape I need it was Logan on a horse
yeah and there's like motorcycles
chasing after him with samurais yeah
that's just Jon wakeful okay there is
not enough amount of Logan yelling
changing this video that's the only
thing weird you want to get our kids
tested on 23 me or my parents Lynch
connection with Gene Hackman gene I'll
never get old now one thing that x-men
origins gave us it's true gene yeah see
Will Smith is the judy judy
alright guys well thanks for tuning and
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification they'll hit that
like button and subscribe to top screen
Thank You Lance door we'll catch you
guys soon